in Venezuela a showdown at the Colombian
border is heating up opposition
supporters have confronted soldiers who
closed a key crossing point troops fired
tear gas at rock throwing protestors in
the Venezuelan border town of arena
early this morning the clashes erupted
as supporters of opposition leader Huang
Gordo prepared to escort humanitarian
aid across the border a correspondent
hargrade us is at the Colombian border
for US jávea there have been clashes
early this morning what more can you
tell us about that well we've seen
several clashes the ones you mentioned
already in the report and also in
Venezuela the leader in Nicolas Maduro
has apparently tried to use all the
state resources in order to ensure that
no one actually reaches the border with
Colombia let's not forget that there's
two stories happening today the one in
the Colombian side and the one in the
Venezuelans eye we will focus on the
Colombian side of course because the
press is mainly here but in Venezuela
there's mass mobilizations of people
trying to reach the border to receive
them in a Teheran aid and also to
protest against the government in
several parts of the country so
attention is in the air right here where
we're right now you can see the trucks
perhaps in the back side it's the trucks
with him and in turn eight that there
are you to start that towards the border
in just a matter of hours we heard that
the interim president juan bardo is in
Colombia right now even though he's not
allowed to leave Venezuelan soil how is
he going to get back into Venezuela
well that is perhaps the most important
question here because no one truly knows
if the military is behind who idle or
not he claims that he has friends in the
military and that is certainly true but
the question is are there enough of his
friends to actually mitigate the effect
of nicolas maduro orders and that's the
question did he enter Colombia as the
leader of the government and as the
leader of the military or did he enter
it illegally no one really knows that
for sure
entering Colombia illegally is actually
quite easy we've seen it many times in
the last few days that's why today is
the decisive day where the military
forces will have to choose whether they
stick to nicolas maduro orders or
support Weddell since we were talking
about the the military here
how much backing does Maduro actually
still have especially in the military
this seems to be the big question here
it's definitely being questioned and
even though we can distinguish the heads
of the military always supporting
nicolas maduro and reiterating his
support we do know that the military is
definitely fractioned in general one
could say that the top leaders of the
military are with Maduro but the medium
range and the lower range ranks are
probably supporting wydo because they
are not privileged because they don't
have the money that the elite has and
because their family members their
friends and their colleagues are in need
and they probably will know that once
they decide whom to support their
greatest for us at the Colombian border
thank you so much